okay so the boys diabolical is an
animated anthology series set somewhat
in the boys universe that explores the
characters and the voc corporation the
series is packed with easter eggs hidden
details and a lot of things you miss
that call back to the comic book series
even the title diabolical is named after
billy butch's catchphrase there are some
major motifs they take from the source
material this is seen early on in the
title sequence for the episodes which
heavily features billy butch's dog
terror though he appeared at one point
in the live-action show he's pretty much
been missing from the main series
however this little guy was in a lot of
the comics he was constantly trying to
[ __ ] anything he could which he does in
a number of these openers quick
disclaimer amazon actually sent out the
episodes for review earlier in the week
in a slightly different order than the
way they've been released i haven't had
a chance to work on my part 2 video yet
as my personal life has been pretty
hectic so this will be slightly
reordered from the way you've probably
watched them throughout this video i'm
going to be going over i'm your pusher
followed by an animated short where
pissed off soups kill their parents then
nubian vs nubian before finishing with
laser baby's day out a second video will
cover the episodes that we don't talk
about in this one and you'll still get
everything broken down when you fix this
damn door now i'm your pusher very much
feels like a love letter to the comics
and each character here carries their
original comic design including huey who
was based upon simon pegg peg initially
was going to play him in live action but
he aged up a bit and thus they cast jack
quaid instead however pegg appeared
throughout the series like what we hear
huey in the comics is scottish and billy
also doesn't have a beard but he does
have a much thicker cockney accent they
open in what i believe is vinnie's
comics which is where we met the
character the legend a stanley parody
this comic book creator pretty much
detailed the entire life of the seven to
huey including homelanders origin story
whilst doing this he held up an orange
covered comic with the seven on the
front that is somewhat similar the one
that we see at the beginning of the
century in the background of it is a
plane and it was during this moment in
the comics that the legend told hughie
about what the seven did on 9 11. issue
21 detailed how they were sent in by
vort as a publicity stunt to help a
hijack plane but they ended up having no
idea what they were doing and thus it
crashed the plane crash scene was of
course referenced in the show but it's
way more messed up in the source
material there's also a cover for one of
the boys graphic novels and amongst the
books we can also catch titles these
include the g-men who are basically an
x-men parody and have their own show
coming soon there's also a cold snap a
g-man member as well as black noir but
what we're here for is i'm your pusher
which is playing on the song i'm your
pushy man by curtis mayfield this
appears at the end of the entry and it's
about a drug dealer which sets a tone
for what's to come we meet one called od
who runs narcotics for all the soups and
whatever you want he got it now in the
comics we learned that most of the soups
are sexual sadists that have sworded
parties and we do drop in on one but you
hired huey to run surveillance on
several of these in the source material
and early on these were the missions
that he tended to take part in we can
catch several parodies including a
gemini man kissing two people pyro using
his flame powers to spark up a strange
substance under a spoon and also an
elephant man we also get a group parody
that grows weed and it seems like the
kind of party you'd never want to leave
now the next morning od opens his door
to terror and he's greeted by billy
butcher during their conversation he
brings up jack from jupiter and also a
train who speeds by and snags a packet
that has a shock on it this could be a
note of the deep though he doesn't
appear in the entry however jack from
jupiter does jack from jupiter is a
martian manhunter s hero that appeared
in the comics and at one point during
the pawn parody that lamplighter watched
there's also a nod to queen maeve's
depression and we catch her drinking a
martini which she constantly used to
nurse in the comics who butcher is
interested in though is the great wide
wonder who he's cooked up something for
using frenchie's help after hanging od
over a balcony billy says you'll believe
a can fly which is playing on the
tagline from the original superman movie
after convincing him to do it hughie and
billy meet each other at a park bench
which is a location that appeared at
several points in the comics this is
where the former met billy and also his
girlfriend starlight this town needs an
enema and it comes in the form of the
great wide wonder who's being inducted
into the superhero hall of fame in
attendance are jack from jupiter queen
maeve and also homelander who introduces
ironcast i believe he's a play on the
superman character steel and his name is
of course based on iron man now the
great wide wonder very much has his own
superman moment as he jets up into space
and then flies through the air high is a
kite he creates deafening sonic booms
and flies through iron cast's stomach
which is somewhat ironic as we found out
that he used to drink the blood of kids
who suffered from life-ending diseases
it's a pr disaster but with all things
vogt the seven members play up that
something else is afoot and they say
that galaxias has returned galaxias is a
parody of galactus a giant space dude
that travels through the cosmos feasting
on planets speaking of feasting we get
ironcast's blood everywhere and just in
the same way that he feasted on the
blood of children a seagull now feasts
on him this could be a nod of the
opening of suicide squad but what it
does is call back to the beginning with
terror who grabbed a blood bag out of
the trash and it brings it all together
to show it's all connected
now if you're enjoying the video so far
i'd love for you to be a pusher man for
that like button and also don't forget
to subscribe for videos like this every
day i'm your host paul the soup season
a-hole that likes to milk a good video
now let's get into the rest of these
deep breakdowns so so bad now the next
one we're covering is an animated short
where stuffed soups kill their parents
like heavy spoilers it does what it says
on the tin and we basically follow some
rejected kids as they get revenge on
their parents written by justin roiland
this episode has the exact same
animation style as rick and morty and
justin even voices a character called
papers later on as we learned from the
comic series compound v was used to try
and give kids superhuman abilities but
what they ended up getting was
completely random the more useless ones
were sent to the red river assisted
living but the gifted child center this
is very much playing on xavier's school
for gifted youngsters which is of course
where parents that couldn't handle their
kids being mutants sent them off to go i
don't know if we can show cartoon boobs
on youtube so i'm not gonna go there but
there's several comic book parodies
including a quote-unquote reverse flash
that moves at super slow speeds there's
a beast boy one that can turn into any
animal but he also gets their brain too
as aqua agua a water-based character
parody that's of course playing on
aquaman sunspot from the new mutants in
x-men except this guy melts stuff with
his balls a hulk figure a human tongue
and ghost who's probably playing on
ghosts from the mcu now telling all of
this is a slick narrator who's voiced by
christian slater but i'm not a rapper
now after learning the truth about
compound v they seek revenge on their
self-centered parents and head out on a
killing spree this is to the sound of
hoodie and the blowfish i only want to
be with you which we learned at the
start was the only song that boombox
could play we see slo-mo choke his dad
there's actually a picture of him
crossing a finish line at a race which
is a bit ironic as his son moves so slow
bang's dad has a cap that says bang's
dad and behind him is a poster for a
train we can also see that girl's
parents have several queen made wine
bottles in their fridge along with some
delicious milk now after murdering her
father in a very brutal manner the
homelander shows up probably to take the
fridge and he spam attacks his eye
lasers wiping out everyone except ghost
she swears to her mother she'll be back
and we close out on the narrator
narrating his dad's death and how he
scooped his face off with a spoon before
he started wearing it we cut to his baby
pics with a smile being put across one
with a blood stain just like the joker
joker is known as an unreliable narrator
and and is that an easter egg i don't i
don't know but let's move on before we
think too much now that takes us into
nubian vs nubian the both of which are
major parodies of storm and black
panther in case you don't know the pair
are actually married in the comics and
they even put on african accents at
points from the mcu movies now she
appeared in comics whilst he showed up
in season one and they're voiced by
aisha taylor and don cheadle
respectfully we open with groundhog
robbing a bank and if you're familiar
with the source material you'll likely
recognize him as being the leader of the
g-men like the comics he has hammers for
hands and can't even play his vs5 which
is of course a wart games console voiced
by john dimaggio aka the man behind
bender and futurama we learn this
opening as a staged pr stunt carried out
by vort nubia and the prince fall in
love whilst fighting him and we find out
that they had a daughter together now
over the last eight years they've slowly
fallen out of love and she goes to
groundhog to ask him to fight her
parents once more to stop their divorce
and neither prince reads his daughter a
story and this somewhat feels like it's
in the same vein as the opening of black
panther in her mother's phone she finds
groundhawks number and amongst the
contacts we can see a train in big game
the both of which appeared in the comics
there's also gunpowder a retired supes
that was a member of payback at one
point nubian prince mentions the young
americans another team from the graphic
novels who like having their buttholes
popped she goes to groundhog and after
convincing him to save her parents
marriage they beat the seven shades of
[ __ ] out of him now they bring up that
they're not even in the same continuity
this season and it's kind of a joke at
this point how convoluted everything
seems to be with there being multiple
versions of the same characters across
different timelines beating the crap out
of him makes them fall in love and due
to newbies wear their powers she causes
a storm that night in the morning they
get handed their divorce papers after
arguing about buying coffee and that
brings the episode to a close now the
final entry we're breaking down this
video is a looney tunes knockoff that
seems to be pulling on the cartoon
buddy's day out this was later adapted
into things like the tom and jerry
episode busy buddies and the movie
baby's day out now initially we follow a
vault worker who attends a lab where the
super kids are created beside his bed we
can catch a vorder burger cup and he
goes past the adoption center into one
of the labs a similar environment popped
up in the first season and much like
what we have here there was a baby that
could shoot lasers out of its eyes
behind the holding doors we can see an
electrical kid but one that can spray
poisonous gas and the titular baby this
is the final day of her trial and he
concludes that she has no control over
her powers in his office we see a poster
for starlight and after finding out the
baby is to be terminated he launches a
rescue attempt the villain of this
episode is a supes with a giant brain
and he feels like he's based upon the
whole character who's known as the
leader he also has an outfit similar to
darkwing duck which if you're a 90s baby
you should recognize if you don't and
you had no childhood and i don't want
you watching this video get there get
the hell out of my sight see you chump
now after going to the zoo the swat team
aimed their guns at her but she goes
chew and fires the lasers act chew best
jokes around oh kate bishop you are so
funny that's hilarious that one is the
funniest
inside the zoo we see crocodiles based
on the one from the disney peter pan
film and also piranhas that look like
flounder from the little mermaid there's
also a cardboard cutout of the deep and
a gorilla which kills some of the vault
soldiers the baby in baby's day out also
got a gorilla pen and this helped out
which i think this scene might be a
homage too now one of the swot sounds so
posh saying homage very very
sophisticated breakdowns at the channel
now one of the swat team members ends up
burning themselves with a flamethrower
and they come out looking like wiley
coyote who used to have this happen to
him quite a lot things culminate at a
construction site which is where a lot
of these sorts of episodes often tend to
wind up with the baby crawling across
the steel girder similar to baby's day
out she wants the big jitterbean ball
which is a coffee company that appeared
in the previous episode and it shows up
throughout the season the leader arrives
to kill them and the kid finally gets
control of her powers and she cuts his
head in half calling the guy dada the
pair take down the forces of vort with
her being aimed like billy used the baby
in the first season that's all boys and
this concludes the first part of our
diabolical breakdown i have to say i
really really enjoyed it and obviously
i'd love to hear your thoughts on the
show below we are going to be dropping
our part 2 video very soon so make sure
you subscribed and if you want something
else to watch then check out our
breakdown of the batman which will be
linked on screen right now it's one of
the best videos we've ever made
which isn't that hard let's be honest
and i'd love to see you over there right
after this without the way i've been
paul you've been the best you know you
have and i'll see you in the next one
take care peace